c'était le choc de cette 5e journée du
championnat r4 trappe en rouge 6e avant
la rencontre recevez sur sa pelouse
ozoir le leader invaincu qui n'avait
encaissé que deux buts cette saison
après seulement 26 minutes de jeu les
trappistes ont déjà fait sauter le
verrou de la défense adverse pour mener
3 0
et puis 4 à 0 avant la mi temps avec ce
but du milieu de terrain kaka ou diallo
j'ai l'opportunité de pouvoir faire un
relais avec mon attaquant qui me donne
et dans ce cas là bas je vais je finis
seul face au gardien
c'est pas évident j'ai les biens prises
tant mieux c'est rentré je pense qu'avec
un contrôle sera été plus compliqué là
tout de suite en première intention bien
tant mieux pour l'équipe
malgré quelques offensives d'ozoir en
seconde période le score n'évoluera plus
4 à 0 au coup de sifflet final on peut
pas s'attendre à un score aussi
important après on a fait un très bon
début de match ce qui nous a permis
aussi de d'enchaîner peut-être que aussi
leurs erreurs et ils les ont payées
aussi cash
tant mieux pour nous parce qu'on a aussi
été efficace c'est ce qui nous a manqué
ces derniers matches on est capable de
faire ce genre de choses là
donc aujourd'hui on tant mieux on en a
mis 4 si on pouvait en mettre 5 6 c'est
un autre jour donc tant mieux avec cette
victoire trappe se retrouve à la
deuxième place du classement devant son
adversaire du jour
on est dans la bonne partie maintenant
c'est à nous de trouver cette constance
qui va nous permettre d'enchaîner les
victoires
si possible ou du moins d'enchaîner les
bons résultats on est capable de le
faire
lahatra penser que le sait le prochain
match le plus compliqué faut qu'on va
essayer de bien travailler pour le
prochain match et a ramené le plus
meilleur résultat possible
prochain match pour l'étoile sportive de
trappes dimanche 22 octobre sur la
pelouse de maisons alfort l'avant
dernier du classement